Taylor Swift's fierce vogue cover plus
where with your favorites at Jingle Ball
hi friends Denny here hope you guys had
an awesome weekend I know I did because
my Christmas tree is now up I'm blasting
Mariah Carey and I'm sipping pumpkin
spice lattes like it's my job but enough
about me
because really it's Taylor Swift's world
and we're just living in it am i right
Taylor graces the cover of British Vogue
looking at edgier than ever
it's her first magazine cover since
dropping reputation and if the photos
look familiar it's because the
photographer's Mert and Marcus took her
Vogue photos and the ones for her album
J was clearly excited to share the pics
on Instagram writing it's been a while
since I've done a magazine cover I'm
really happy my first one back was with
such wonderful people Taylor also
performed at her first big show in 10
months over the weekend that's right she
hit the stage I kiss at them I Heart
Radio Jingle Ball concert and to the
delight of Swifties and the star-studded
crowd in the audience Taylor shared the
stage with her BFF ed Sheeran performing
their song end game for the first time
together
[Music]
you don't wanna see
[Music]
and game was part of her six song set
and everybody was pumped meanwhile
former One Direction bandmates Liam
Payne and now Horan had an offstage
reunion they both are on the Jingle Ball
tour and our Katie Kraus spoke with Liam
about hanging with his old pal again and
celebrating his first Christmas with his
son bear it's your first holiday season
as a father
any new traditions that you're looking
forward to starting well I used to go to
Disneyland when I was a kid a lot with
my parents you still go to Florida every
year and I like the idea of taking him
when he's maybe about six that's a way
off yet but that's like my dream what
are you guys doing for this holiday
season you and the family well I have a
little nephew that she's been born as
well who's younger than bear little baby
Ashton and so it's gonna be very baby
full house I imagine the happiness and
love around to be amazing you mentioned
Niall he's on stage right now how has it
been reuniting with him on the Jingle
Ball tour I think I mean we played a bit
of PlayStation this thing in my hotel
room in San Jose I got a lot complaints
having my feet on the bed I'm sorry
about that it just died just happened
and then yeah it's been fantastic came
hung out for a little bit but it's just
so nice to see him I mean I don't know
when you see someone you haven't seen
for ages and you become the same person
you were when you with I don't know it's
very interesting any chance of you guys
collaborating on stage at all I mean I
get up and sing about slow hands
so I gotta say it's amazing to see the
1d guys have so much solo success
something fifth Harmony's Lauren Jared
why is starting to experience herself
she's branching out from 5h and was also
at Jingle Ball and watch her blush about
her new man ty dolla side hobby reach in
here and pick a question out of our
Santa hats okay Santa have so tuned who
do you plan to kiss under the mistletoe
this season you have a new man right I
love how glowy and smiley you just got
yeah yeah about him that you love the
most
he's just amazing like treats me
counting up it kind of nice to be on
your own a little bit and doing all
these features aside with fifth harmony
obviously if someone to love for them
but is it nice to explore that wow yeah
all of us are exploring it right now you
know we're at such an amazing place
harmoniously with each other with
communication and just like support for
one another that like you know we've
grown so much over the past year even
and and I love genuinely being able to
explore myself and know that my girls
are like there for me and it's the same
for all of us so it's really cool
because we're just kind of branching out
to creatively discover ourselves cuz we
never really got an opportunity to do
that since we started this one we're
like six I was 16 when I started you
know so put you guys together exactly so
you have to kind of conform to like what
fifth harmony would be when essentially
not any one of us is that on our own you
know what I mean so it's cool to be able
to give each other that space to really
explore ourselves individually and grow
well keep on growing girl
alright guys signing off for the day but
if you liked what you saw today let me
know give us a like and a share on this
video and we will be back tomorrow good
bye